the burnout happens because people are
posting what they think is going to get
the most likes and Views instead of what
they actually want to post I saw a ton
of burnout from Attractive people the
people that built Their audience on like
taking off their shirt and showing their
abs or going all TNA on everything like
they were burning out because a lot of
them got to a different price in their
life and they wanted to talk about other
but they weren't getting the same
action on likes and they were like
literally doing they didn't want to
do like I see a lot of comedians
struggle with this they're saying the
same jokes that they know will do well
but their humor has evolved and so
everyone's conforming to what they think
will do well versus posting what they
want to post the best way to not burn
out is to post what you want to post
even if it doesn't do as well as
that you used to do I would bite for you
talking about the things you want to
talk about and too many people also
think it's not a good strategy to talk
about a bunch of different on their
account and I think it's the reverse